good morning gamers
or should i say good evening we're back
in the most beautiful minecraft world
on the planet we got water now
gamers it looks sick all the way around
i will show you actually we'll get the
elantra today so
we can fly around it should look epic
look at those melons
look at my factory it's glorious i'm so
proud of it
but yeah it's time it's time to get the
electra i'm hyped dude
shut up you're there to supply cat girl
water for my potions not to communicate
get out yeah don't even look at me bunky
you're the man
i love you look how cool this is it took
me ages
it was awful look at bonky looks like a
weird album cover look at it
just me yeah all right well i thought
water around would be cool
because then at least mobs can't spawn
and i don't have to light up with
torches everywhere like i did over there
like that looks kind of ugly and
i already have so many shroom lights
that i just thought it would be a bit
much but i don't know y'all tell me what
you think i i don't know
uh yeah all right we got our potions
i want to get some ender pearls it's all
right we don't need we actually don't
need ender pearls
and we're up
this is amazing i'm already on fire
all right well we had the speed buff i
might as well hurry up
i'm so excited for the new minecraft
update
it looks actually insane i mean the
nether update was
obviously huge as well but i mean this
is cool
well this is basically what we're gonna
do today build a
ton of bridges i'm actually gonna kill
some enderman because i want some pearls
but my god are they annoying where did
he go
okay that's how it's done don't let him
teleport basically
all right the dragon egg i forgot about
it okay let's get the dragon egg
okay so i know i can just i can just
look online right
but i had a feeling that this is how you
do it and i i'm not sure
to be honest with you all right let's
try it
yeah it worked cool got the dragon egg
the rarest item in minecraft my dudes
no i need the piston thank you hey bro i
got the dragon egg brah
so i saw philsa responded to
the whole thing that i might die in the
nether because of a glitch
it's kind of funny because the
enderpearl landed on an edge
and i was so scared that i was gonna
fall off and i think i'm i mean i could
be wrong again
but i think that's how he died because
he threw a pearl through this
it made him land on the edge but instead
of standing still it sort of like
the game just made him float off the
edge which is such a sh
way to die uh sorry i need to rub it in
filter
not gonna happen to me i really thought
that would work for some reason
why why does the beacon do that stop it
all right there we go we're tiny now
gamers
why does it put me in the edge stop it
mo
jang oh god it's so nerve wrecking
all right well it's better i guess it
beats
like uh why am i here
yes it beats throwing a pearl because
i'm always scared that i'm gonna admit
all right we're here now gamers
on top of the world what a strange game
anyway
can you bring your horse through there i
wonder why am i thinking about this i
don't know
these are the real questions okay that
looks like a fat
oh oh that's so strange why did they do
i never seen that before so there's
another exit on that island basically
all right this is the [ __ ] worst but
uh we're gonna have to build a bridge
here
i hate it i hate it so much it just
feels bad man
bro just hold shift okay sure what if i
aggroed an enderman and he pushes me off
then what
i hate this i hate this i hate this i
hate this i hate this i hate this
i hate this so much baller
ballin so there's that thing it doesn't
help us though
it doesn't help me i need the ender what
is that
what is that that's an end city holy
[ __ ] that's a ship
oh my god that was so fast nice
let's go cool oh it looks so
cool in with the shaders oh look at that
y'all want to see some balling [ __ ] dare
me to jump
oh i don't know man is it worth it
let me see how much i float not that
much
i don't know should i no i'm two sounds
i'm too scared what if i just build
myself really high and then i float over
will that make you guys less anxious
[Music]
we're just gonna float don't worry about
it bro don't worry about it bro
don't be scared bruh hold my hand bruh
this is how the pros do it
go go go go pearl
yeah that was so cool i wasn't even
scared man
man that was so easy all right here we
go
i can't believe how fast i found it
usually they're quite difficult so and
yeah
uh some end cities i am not sure but i
think some of them spawn without the
boat but it's the boat that has the
actual elytra in it
which is cool oh and there's an exit
right there too
look at us couple of minecraft gamers
so we're not completely safe here i'm
not gonna lie
like because now we'll get the shulker
boxes oh my god
finally we'll get the shulker boxes hey
i'm back gamers a whole day has passed
not for you but for me so anyway here we
are
let's just dig our way through gamers i
like these purple blocks they're so cool
oh yeah we gotta watch out for these
guys oh god
no it's happening it's happening okay
all right
stop it are these guys dangerous should
i be scared
nah bro just die bro i want your shulker
they didn't drop any are you serious
yeah they did they did
give me give me give me give me yes
finally oh my god i can get so much sand
now
i can't wait to get the sand let me get
all these blocks i don't know what i'll
do with it
okay i probably shouldn't have removed
all the blocks
[Music]
there we go boom so i watched on the
outside this is a really small end city
so this shouldn't take forever like this
can sometimes do
all right [ __ ] it i'll jump ah guys
please are they hitting each other
all right here we go hey guys how's it
going
great you're all going to die
this is fantastic
oh what the hell
ow oh god they're so annoying honestly
stop i have really good armor you have
no
chance okay i'm actually kind of high
now i'm getting a little
sorry i should probably eat something
right
[ __ ]
all right
well we're still flying all right i'm at
the top
gamers thanks for the lift oh my god
this is ridiculous
the panic is when this happens on your
outside and you start flying up and up
and you're like oh god i'm going to die
all right was that it okay let's check
the chest
diamond sword and beat
oh fire protection finally
okay for real though i really want these
n rods that's what i'm talking about
it's all about the end rods i want
every single little piece girl give me
your end rod
say that to a girl in the club she'll be
all over you trust me my dude
oh there's one still alive to still
alive
stop it guys you're embarrassing
yourself these are my
end rods you can't stop me how do you
think i met marzia
girl let me leave your head wrong girl i
don't think you can craft them though i
think the only chance to get them is
here and they they do like i don't know
there's something about the shape of
them
i like them is that it no this one down
here
oh it's so dark and spoopy now i don't
like it
now okay let's just gotta be a little
careful here
because there will definitely be them
and they're not going to get me
i hear them they're usually by the
entrance yeah they're there
oh geez you can't hit them
dumb so dumb they're so dumb
i hear another one i don't like it hey
bro
i'm sorry oh my god there's an end chest
i have played this entire game without
an end chess which i have absolutely no
reason to use now that i have a shulker
god dang it guys
we had a deal i thought we had a deal
the hell he shot it back at me how did
that
diamond
so i don't think i can grab this no i
need south touch
sad you gotta be careful here on the
outside
because they shoot you stop it stop it
stop it
cool it guys cool it guys oh geez
no i don't want to be hit here i don't i
actually don't where's this guy
there he is i see him
got him all right we gucci my gamers
definitely don't want to fall
whoa okay it goes all the way there
that's kind of cool can i go inside
guys you forgot the stairs cringe
okay yeah i see you
little stinker nope
how you doing
screw the elytra man man just want the
rods
some people want to beat the dragon so
they can fly
others they just want nice long rods
can you blame me really all right what's
their chest in here or what
i want another diamond that'd be so cool
if i could get a diamond
in this game i would just love it so
much
please mojang a diamond what would be an
item that would actually excite me to
find i
don't know i feel like i have it all
suffering from success god damn it guys
not now
i'm collecting my rods are you a piece
of crack
are you stinker
ah well good thing i have bomb ass armor
it doesn't matter so hard to see them
they're there
there we go how many shulkers have i got
eight i don't know how many that makes
but yeah i've actually legitimately this
is really weird
in my other playthrough i never used
shulker boxes i never realized what they
were for
i never understood their purpose
we'll definitely do that they seem hella
useful
so yeah they like trays on the bow so
we'll have to that's the
the last mission after the rods the rods
comes first gamers
all right are we at the top looks so
cool
come on look at this so still
i love it only one place left gamers
i think here is like where you've
actually beaten the game if you done the
end city you get the elytra
that's when you beat the game right
there's nothing else after that
it's kind of sad in a way it kind of
fits this somber vibe
that we got going on if i die trying to
collect end rods
and i i don't know what i'll do
guys 69 and rods
kill me i loot this i can't remember yes
it was a beat
i forgot the beetroot seed sorry guys my
bad there we go
oh this [ __ ] sucks
all right there we go last piece of the
puzzle
oh you expect me to just walk
[ __ ] sake fine
oh [ __ ] that's bad
okay got him
oh [ __ ] open up
[ __ ] daddy nice
more more end rods
please enchantment table
instant i'll take it right
what is that oh it's supposed to be the
must i don't know what that's called in
english
oh yeah that's the dragon at the top i
forgot about that nice
oh there's one more where my dude i'm
getting the head
the head is mine you cannot stop what up
mr
ender dragon who's apparently a female i
apologize
yes the best item in the game
yes it makes me laugh every time it's so
[ __ ] dumb
oh man i'm easily entertained what can i
say
ah he's in here the last
defender too bad you is gonna die
[Music]
there they are first of all garbage so
touch all right i'll yeah sure sure i'll
take it
but i will keep my beat seats and i will
replace you
uh slab unbreaking three fire protection
for
death strike they're not bad obviously
but like no
i don't diamonds yay
fire protection mending aqua infinity
mending
don't need them don't eat them i really
don't need them
and there we go sky's the limit we got
the elytra
amazing we did it gamers it's time
to fly home game us okay just to be safe
i'm gonna use the push and falling here
because i i don't know if i remember
which button you click right
all right here we go gamers
wow i'm playing
it was space
[Applause]
such speed such elegance
i'm not falling i'm flying with style or
whatever
yeah me oh and runs more androids i'm
coming
don't worry and right i will not forget
you
i'm coming at a very slow velocity
dies i mean i've seen a lot of people
in hardcore die from the what are you
doing
die from the elytra because they fly
into something
too quickly it's easy to let that happen
we gotta put mending on and on breaking
on this bad boy excuse me
excuse me i'm doing done coming through
i already built this
here we go back home
thought i could make it out
[Music]
hey donkey we look the same now how
about that incredible
i feel good all right it's time for our
test flight right
oh i wasn't wearing it see that's enough
that's another thing you think you wear
it and then you realize you don't
i've seen it happen why should i put all
the end stuff i don't
i guess it's time to expand my storage
huh oh my end rods
i think they'll look cool they're cool
light source unironically i mean that
feels kind of baller to just throw your
diamonds into your sorting system
all right uh i need to trade
good thing i'm rich this economy is
uh has been good to me unbreaking three
please
thank you kindly sir i'm not sure you
can put them breaking on it but i hope
so
no
no no
no
i hate you
you [ __ ]
i'm dying i'm dying smiling i'm dying
smiling i'm dying smiling
stop it
i'm too health calm down stoic brother
play well don't be [ __ ] change to
health potion switch over
[Music]
murder them murder them
those [ __ ] [ __ ]
why didn't you die instead who else
oh you guys are fine
[Music]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] slag
oh my god lightning stroke why do they
keep
hitting them why do you keep getting hit
by lighting
i gotta have to build a roof over you
now you know how much that's gonna cost
me
you know how much money that's gonna
cost you understand
are you guys fine at least oh my god
all right let's look at the damage we
lost
looting three okay fine protection for
annoying mending q loyalty
infinity i don't need that fire
protection all right
wait you still still touch i don't even
know bro
awesome all right it's fine i i know i
have an ending somewhere
oh what a tragedy i can't get over it so
can i put i'm breaking on it i can
okay but i think that's
it that's all you can put okay all right
trying to not get annoyed
but yeah i'm gonna have to get a new
mending guy now
mending guy was like father to me you
know oh it's about to get dark
it's just the perfect time to take our
first flight
here we go guys
[Music]
this series has been an absolute
pleasure
thank you all for supporting it there it
is
holy sh that it looks better than i
thought
oh i'm so proud dude
this is just the beginning
we started off with the glass meeple
oh my gosh i love it
i never taken minecraft seriously before
but it was so fun to do that
and see what i was capable of this is
such a cool start
i want to keep building it's so fun it's
legitimately the best game
i can love minecraft unironically
and i hope you guys can accept me saying
that now
after all these years i am officially
a minecraft veteran
oh hell yeah
alright gamers signing off a brofist